hey what's going on this is yahya abdul
mateen ii and i'm here with buzzfeed
today to read your thirst tweets i'm a
little bit afraid of what he's gonna say
because my timeline be a little bit off
the hook see what y'all got
yahya is one beautiful chocolate man
that's tame that's very tame i'll take
it y'all still find that my eyes water
when i see him i don't cry sweetheart
yahya is fine af dark skin has a beard
wears gold grills and can cook i'm ready
whenever he is all right girl don't you
know don't threaten me with no good time
you're talking about you know you're
putting all the things i love my beard
you know my grill i love cooking mess
around and get snatched up it's always
you can't find love on tinder and never
here's my close friend yahya abdullah
mateen and i think y'all will hit it off
i'm not really the type to be like
hooked up i don't really kind of go for
the hook up thing cause i don't like
people in my business so once you get
hooked up then that's automatically
three people in your business so nah
unfortunately that's a little bit true
candyman look fantastic but how many
times do i need to say yahoo before he
ends up in my bed
is about as close as we've gotten to
perfection the skin the lips the talent
the energy he can have all my things
what things you talking about girl
behave you should tweet me compliments
more often if you tweet me i'll read
them in the morning i'll make a calendar
of all your tweets i'll just for every
month it'll be a different tweet and
i'll just read it and keep my confidence
like that finally started watchmen and
i've done a kegel every time yahoo has
come on screen
that's funny like i just want god to
bless me with a gentle man with legs as
long as yahya's please girl what you
know about these long legs who is that
that reminds me of something my
grandmothers used to say she used to
make me say this ever since i was this
this big she said you're long you're
tall you built for speed got everything
a woman need the fellas hate me because
i speak my mind and the ladies love me
because i take my time y'all can break
my back like a glow stick any time of
the day hashtag respectfully all right
you better holla at me i appreciate the
respectfully because respectfully is
important but getting your back broke
like a glow stick is also important too
thanks buzzfeed it's been a pleasure
everybody make sure to check out
candyman in theaters soon peace
[Music]
you